going to get into rational functions
shortly however just going around I've
seen lots of people independently
struggling with a particular pile of
this question so I figure it's worth
addressing now okay you can see I've got
my why is worse than or equal to x 3
minus portion is my parabola and y is
less than the absolute value of x so
there's my bouncy line and there's my
green region okay but the last thing is
left it's lasting most people saw is the
points of intersection okay now
unfortunately because the numbers it
does turned out to involve some
irrational numbers okay so we're going
to have to work this out conscious look
at that okay but there's a point of
confusion because of this absolute value
right because if you solve it right if
for instance you go absolute value of x
right what's that equal to that's X and
minus X right so you think ok I've got
to solve this equation that'll give me
some points of intersection and then you
solve this equation okay and when you
solve both of these you'll get two
solutions two solutions for solutions
which ones are they okay and that's
that's what people are confused about
okay so I think what we'll do is we take
a step back this question is not as high
as it looks partly as well because of
the symmetry we've got here both of
these functions that even functions so
their points of intersection will just
be you know a and minus a okay just
flipped around so we shouldn't have that
much work to actually find the values of
this right but just assuming we didn't
know about even symmetry okay how would
we solve this anyway all you know if
they weren't even what would you do
let's start with actually labeling the
branches of the graph as they're
different right so this part over here
the one that's going up ok this is what
a gradient that's increasing so that's y
equals x and other one is negative x
okay now I like positive numbers because
they're easier to do it so I'm just
going to think about this part over here
okay but the important to get about this
line y equals x right is it doesn't go
through the entire graph it doesn't go
on forever right it's got all these
positive values but then it stops at x
equals zero
right so way of saying that is y is
equal to x when x is greater than zero
and only when x is batting zero and that
would be important in a second so you go
ahead to solve this you want to find the
point of intersection so you solve
simultaneous that you go x is equal to x
squared minus 4 i'm your rearranged have
everything on one side sorry you stare
for a little while to try and factorize
it and then realize you can't so you go
to the quadratic formula right oh what
you did right that's what I did okay so
I think in the end you get something
like what r 1 plus the square root of 17
yeah yeah on 2 that's to it okay sorry
plus or minus yeah so here's mine is my
two solutions right but i know i don't
want both of them because when actually
look at my graph this party r and this
party only intersect was so I'm gonna
have to exclude one of the questions
which one depends on this okay so these
two value is 1 minus the square root of
17 and 1 plus the square root of
segments okay if I only what the
positive one what must be positive and
one must be negative okay now you don't
need a calculator to work out which ones
which okay because which one is bigger
this is a plus innocent minus so this
must be we go another way of thinking
about it is the square root of 17 I
don't know what it is but it's got to be
close to the square root of sixteen
which is what so you are like 1-4 that's
a negative okay so i would say but x is
greater than 0 okay this is why it's
important to look down your domain
before you start anything therefore x is
equal to just this one okay now there's
my coordinates u 1 plus the square root
of 17
or two and I guess you'd sub that in if
you don't need to suffer them because
the y and X values to be the same so 1
plus the square root of two okay there's
one intersection point in this example
like I said before it's even so you can
just read off the graph and say bye even
symmetry right this will be minus one
minus the square root 17 on too but the
Y value is the same right because over
the same it's it's positive when they're
not even you can't just do that what are
you going to be forced to do redo this
but for the other side so you're going
to say well on that side of God minus X
for when X is negative right and then
you keep on going you'll get to this
point okay and you'll say x is equal to
let's see here I'm going to have minus 1
minus from 17 24 minus 1 plus root 70
knots okay and exactly the same way or
reverse I guess you say I've only want
the negative 1 and this is not negative
right so you exclude it just like we did
before if you get one solution may wait
that one ok so that's how you learn
which routes you're interested in